And there's two answers that are correct here--namely, the first two ones.
So the error actually comes from the rounding because as we discussed before--
if we did not round, then the table size will be changed and also the solution that we get.
So the objects that we picked wouldn't change, but through these rounding down here,
what can happen is that two objects that actually have a different value
now appear to the algorithm to have the same value.
So the algorithm say of objects V₁ and V₂ and we're going to do an example here to say--
V₁ has a value of 8 and V₂ has a value of 9, and we're now choosing this x here to be 2,
then V₁ gets the scale down value of 4 and V₂ gets the scale value of 4.5.
Now, assuming that both objects have the same size, it would be better to take V₂ instead of V₁,
but now if we round down, both objects get a scales down value of 4,
so the algorithm might pick V₁ over V₂, although that is sub-optimal, but the algorithm
can't tell anymore because both objects in terms of value look the same to the algorithm.
The cool thing is that we can actually specify and quantify how large that error is going to be.
So this is not right. We can't specify it and this is exactly what we are now going to do.